all right people of the internet this is
the Reuben report and welcome to another
Friday Round Table Extravaganza joining
me today is the opinion editor of
Newsweek Josh hammer and the independent
sub stack journalist and author of the
gray lady winked Ashley rinsberg Josh
Ashley welcome to the Reuben report
always a pleasure
Josh you've been on many times the
audience is familiar with Josh Hammer so
I want to give Ashley a moment on his
debut Reuben report episode to just tell
everyone a bit about himself and and a
bit about the book because I think they
will see why I thought you were a good
fit for today's show
yeah thank you so much Dave I um as you
mentioned I'm an investigative
journalist independent I don't have a
unfortunately for my bank account don't
have any corporate Masters but um I get
by so I wrote this book in 2021 about
the New York Times called the gray lady
winked actually I published in 21 I
wrote it many years before but it was uh
blocked at every turn by the publishing
industry which did not want this book
out and this book is about the 10 cases
that the New York Times misreporting
actually changed history so this is all
the way from Walter Durante denying the
Ukraine famine in the early 1930s right
up until today Nicole Hannah Jones
trying to convince America that we are a
slave Nation rather than a nation based
in Liberty and everything in between so
that is the gray lady winked and you
know really struck a chord of course as
we're talking a lot about media today
and media corruption malfeasance and the
kind of distortion that they weave into
all of our Lives yeah the book is really
excellent and my audience will totally
dig it because yeah the New York Times
Ashley you I'm guessing they didn't put
you on the New York Times bestseller
list
they did not and you know that is an
editorial list that is not a numbers
list they make they make those choices
by by whoever they want to include and
exclude that's why you don't see a lot
of conservative authors on that list
proportionate to their sales yeah it's
hilarious as everyone knows and then
we'll move on my my first book made it
to the list I should have been number
four they put me at 11. my second book
should have been number two possibly
number one depending on how they counted
by sales and they didn't even put me on
I mean and it's like the only reason I
even mentioned it I truly don't care the
first time I wanted my Editor to get it
because it was good for her career I
didn't care I make fun of the New York
Times all the time but the point is that
if they literally mess with sales
numbers which are hard numbers it's like
do you think they might be messing with
some of those other 10 things that you
mentioned uh all right so let's just
dive right into it guys and I want to
talk about independent journalism
because Josh you're kind of on both
sides of these things as a Twitter guy
and a Newsweek guy uh Joe Rogan uh this
week had a nice summation of what's
going on here uh when it comes to the
failure of mainstream media and why
independent journalists are so important
right now because if it was not for
independent journalism we would be in a
pickle we would be in a really bad State
because a lot of people got duped by the
pharmacy the pharmacological
industry the pharmaceutical industry the
the medical industry the industrial
military-industrial complex they've been
duped by so many different companies and
corporations that have a vested interest
in getting one narrative out and if you
can get that narrative out through the
traditional pipelines of mainstream
media with no one fact checking no one
interfering no independent journalist
saying actually that's not true at all
here's why they did that this was the
influence here's where the money is we
have emails we can show you they were
influenced if it wasn't for them we
would be and it's one of the
beautiful things about the internet
today the internet today allows people
like that to thrive five because these
mainstream media corporations are so
corrupt they're so obviously indebted to
the companies that pay for their
advertising actually I always tell my
audience I don't consider myself a
journalist I think I think other people
do I just tell people what I think for a
living and then I chat with other people
and my opinions are what they are but I
suppose this has become a type of
Journalism because mainstream media's
journalism has become so negligent I
take it this is not a surprise to you
no I mean we they've created a void
they've created a huge gap and people
have filled it because there's a
necessity we this is the thing I think
people want to throw out the baby with
the bathwater and say journalism is bad
it's it's evil and journalists are Enemy
of the State and nothing could be
further from the truth I mean the the
epigram of my book is a Thomas Jefferson
quote saying if he could have a state
without newspapers or newspapers without
a state he would take the latter
newspapers are more important to Thomas
Jefferson than the state itself but
that's not true when the newspapers
become aligned with the state and start
taking dictates from the FBI State
Department the White House you name it
they are no longer serving that critical
role that's exactly what Rogan was
pointing out Josh I wish I could say the
word journalist without using air quotes
all the time but it's become mostly
impossible uh one of the things you're
doing at Newsweek with the op-ed section
is you're trying to get a plurality of
voices back in there it went very far
left you've obviously brought it back
more to the center but what do you make
of the General State as someone you know
you're at Newsweek so you're around the
General State of kind of Legacy Media is
there anything left there or should we
just be saying goodbye to them and move
on
so I mean the General State I think of
mainstream media the New York Times
Obviously being a perfect Avatar of that
is pretty pretty bad I mean I I'm a
little biased obviously I happen to
think that a lot of what's going on in
Newsweek perhaps especially the op-ed
section that I've been privileged to
oversee for the last three years or so
we're trying to do something a little
different to your credit Dave but I have
to say I mean I I'm not sure how well
this will sit with my Twitter followers
and whatnot but like you Dave I very
much eschew the label journalists I do
not I do not think of myself as a
journalist um I I don't I don't do
investigative reporting personally I
write opinion columns and I solicit
opinion columns and I host podcasts and
things like that so I'm very much in the
opinion business but I I I I just want
to Echo what Joe Rogan said and really
what Ashley is doing here I love
substack I just absolutely love kind of
the Revolution to journalism that
substack has brought over the past few
years I think you'll see some kind of in
the corporate vestigial media in the
times Washington Post that kind of crowd
that kind of scorns substance can very
much use it as potential competition and
things like that at least from where I'm
sitting in my own personal capacity as
an opinion editor and it's indicated
columnist I just love it I love the fact
that people are able to kind of get
their words out there without any kind
of filter without any kind of
restriction and I definitely think that
it has made good quality investigative
journalism the likes of which the
mainstream media very infrequently does
at this point much much easier is the
just trying to give the devil is due
here I mean is the problem with that
though that we end up with everyone just
siphoning off to their own whatever they
agree with and then no one can really
fact check it now of course I say that
with irony because who's fact checking
the fact Checkers and usually the fact
Checkers uh are partisan hacks so it's
just really really complex right Ashley
yeah it's it's a hard thing to negotiate
but I think that's kind of on both sides
of it it's kind of you're pointing out
Dave which is that you could have stuff
going on in the New York Times that
would make people on substack blush and
that that actually is the case I mean we
look at the coverage of covid we look at
the coverage of uh Russia gate and you
had every layer of the of the editorial
structure there just amplifying the
mistruths and the falsehood under the
guise of this being totally credible so
it kind of worked against the reader to
have all this structure of editorial
oversight whereas on substack you at
least have kind of accountability like
you know who the person is and you know
what they're saying and you know
probably more or less why they're saying
it whereas with these big corporate
structures you've got no idea what's
going on behind the scenes you've got no
idea what are the corporate incentives
the shareholders pushing for some
storyline the government getting
involved there's so much interference at
these big organizations that it totally
negates all that careful oversight and
structure that they've built yeah you
know one line that I always use on this
is that truth has become a Time release
pill and it's like you only have to look
at the last couple years of covert where
there were a whole bunch of us I'm sure
you guys included Josh I know you for
sure saying you know things that now we
all accept as true about covet or most
of us except is true about covid and
they just simply were not allowed to be
said on mainstream media you know Wuhan
lab leak nobody could say it on
mainstream media until Jon Stewart said
it on Colbert and then suddenly
everybody started saying it like they
wait for these airlocks to be lifted I
want to show you this clip this is
really wild and if you watch mainstream
media you probably didn't see the
original clip but Matt taibi who is a
sub stack journalist a lefty I think
he's a self-proclaimed Progressive uh he
was testifying at uh at Congress it was
on the weapon weaponization of
government and while he was doing it the
IRS showed up at his house okay I mean
you cannot make this stuff up the
scriptwriters aren't even doing that
well here it's just too obvious so
anyway Chris Stewart who's a republican
congressman from Utah he asked treasury
secretary Janet Yellen about that this
is a day or two after it happened about
the IRS showing up at a journalist's
house as he is reporting or as he is
testifying about the weaponization of
government take a look
let's see
thank you
there's something about like her energy
her like just general State that's
hilarious right I mean look I don't know
exactly what that had to do with it why
you would ask Janet Yellen that question
so I'll sort of give her a little bit of
a pass of it seems that she should have
been at least aware of it but but okay
so be it Josh the broader Point here
that they're showing up to the guy's
house he's not under investigation it
sounds like it's possible the government
might have actually owed him a little
bit of money they generally don't show
up to give you cash I mean what is going
on here
so real quick on the Jenny yellow point
in particular you know just looking at
this visual of this woman who is clearly
elderly just saying that she is not
aware of what's going on to me it's
perfect right I mean it just underscores
that we are living in what some
commentators have referred to as a
gerontocracy which is kind of just a an
oligarchy basically of elderly people I
mean 65 and up and I think that exchange
right there with the younger Congressman
kind of the older uh you know treasury
secretary you really kind of saw that
juxtaposition right there but to what
you're asking about Dave I mean look
Chris Stewart there was estimating the
odds would be one in a million I mean
frankly he's probably lowballing it I
would guess probably even lower odds
than that if I had to guess there talk
about just a ridiculous chilling of the
first amendment I mean what Matt taibi
has done is just exposed Bladen
government corruption the government
working hand in hand with the big Tech
oligarchs all the Twitter files you know
I know that you know that Dave very well
but man I I mean I have never heard of
an IRS agent showing up to someone's
home either but to do so so literally
while you are testifying on at the
weaponization committee I mean like you
said I mean like if you were writing
this in Hollywood people would laugh it
off and say dude you're just taking this
a little too far but such is the reality
of what we're dealing with right it's
just two on the nose I feel like I got
to tell my social media guy Brock we got
to put together her Greatest Hits
inflation is transitory remember the
other day climate change is part of our
monetary policy and uh this one I'm not
aware it's like we got to put that to
music or something uh Ashley in a weird
way when I heard this that that this IRS
agent showed up at his house I was just
like yeah of course they did of course
they did because nothing is too over the
top here at this point
well I mean remember one of the lines of
questioning from Debbie Wasserman
Schultz in the hearing was did you make
money did you profit if she's asking
taibi if he made money from the Twitter
files work he did and he you know he had
to kind of tell her well I invested
money
um and she kept pressuring and pushing
and pushing and she was obviously
sending a message to him that we're
paying attention to your finances and
then this happens and of course it's a
message I mean nobody does that without
wanting to send a message to him and to
people around him and to people like me
watching from the outside to say watch
out you better watch your back because
we're looking at you and we know that
they're watching us we know they're
looking at us we know that from the
Twitter files we know that the level of
interference has become stratospheric
they are leaving nothing to chance
they're playing this extremely tight and
they're not playing by any of the rules
that we think apply those are all gone
so I think this was a clear message I
don't think anyone would take the chance
of this leaking out unintentionally if
they didn't intend it I think that is
absolutely what happened yeah I think
you're right that's it's like it's
intentionally like look what we do as
I've mentioned on the show several times
before uh you know I campaigned with
Larry Elder for the recall election
against Gavin Newsom obviously did not
go well I think three days later I was
audited by the state of California
that's actually the same day that I put
my house for sale no joke I was like
that's it I already wanted to get out I
was done but that was officially like
we're we're leaving and I can't stay
here let's move on because the other the
other big story of the week obviously
was this shooting in Tennessee and it
turns out that this was a apparently it
was a biological female who was at least
going by male pronouns it's unclear to
me if she was actually transmitting had
surgery but it sounds like there's
probably some level of hormones or
testosterone we're going to find out all
about that but I want to again focus on
the the media version of this here is
MSNBC Joy Reed and as far as I know Joy
Reid did not bring on any of the victims
or victims families or perhaps a pastor
from the church or anything like that
here she is with trans Advocate
Charlotte Clymer who I think she is he
she whatever is trans oh so oh just
watch I think children are only unsafe
at drag shows when a shooter shows up to
kill them that's right that's where the
threat is I would challenge anyone just
to get to know trans people we are a
vibrant diverse Community as diverse as
anyone else you know I'm from the great
state of Texas I served in the military
I go to church every Sunday my faith is
very important to me but God Made Me In
Her Image God made me transgender
and to see these people so cynically
weaponize this and exploit these
children's debts and their teachers
debts
it breaks my heart I wonder what those
families are thinking right now what do
you what do you feel when you have
somebody like Michael knows at CPAC we
need to eradicate transgenderism and
when somebody like Tucker Carlson says
that transgender people are at war with
Christians I can't see Christ in their
words that's for damn sure I can't see
where the biblical principles of loving
your neighbor
and walk in the walk with Christ that
they can see I can't see what they're
saying right now because that's son of
Christ it's not
okay well first off Charlotte climber on
Twitter runs around calling everybody
racist and bigoted and certainly he's
not using Christ in uh his or her words
uh but the fact that
that that's what they're talking about
as opposed to the obvious to me if you
go into a school and you shoot children
you obviously are mentally ill let's
remove the trans part there's obviously
a mental health issue here uh for all of
these people that do this uh Ashley this
is just standard media 101 because this
case a trans person person shooting
Christians doesn't fit the narrative had
it been the other way they could have
dealt with this in a whole much bigger
way and it would be it would be way
bigger right if a Christian went in and
shot some trans people now we have a
story that fits the narrative we can run
with that
yeah and we also have this like a very
confused narrative about the about the
gender because it's usually put on boys
and men as being violent and here it's
like really which one do you go with and
it create it just completely distorts
that narrative that has been run by the
media
um so yeah I think that this has been a
a real muddled case for them and the
fact that they are a once again imposing
a narrative here where sure you might
want to have a conversation here and
there about guns and here and there
about the what's going on with
transgender people but mental health is
the thing that is not being addressed
you cannot talk about people walking
into a any place a school a church
anywhere and killing many people without
any any motive any cause any any reason
that you can point to without this being
a conversation about whatever is going
on whether that's psychosis whether that
is who who knows we don't we don't know
because we don't even talk about it this
is where it is and instead the media has
used this once again as a wedge it's a
wedge issue to push people apart from
each other to make it US versus them
instead of to think about problem and
solution it's also fascinating because
it's not just that they don't talk about
it they go out of their way not to talk
about it the view this week would be
made a huge point about how it had
nothing to do with mental illness this
was clearly about guns and if you guys
remember the Uvalde shooting Joy Reid
went on air the next night and opened
her show by saying this had nothing to
do with mental illness there's simply no
way she could have known that it was
less than 24 hours after the shooting
and again from where I sit by by the
very definition of the action
it is mental illness uh Josh not not
much sanity coming out of MSNBC huh no
typically not I mean there's so many
layers of this story in the media and
the media reaction to it to unpack but I
think your point is a very good one
which is we as a society as Americans in
general are far too reticent far too
unwilling to discuss mental illness and
talk about its many ramifications so
just this past weekend Dave I was in
your old stomping grounds I was in Los
Angeles I was out there for a wedding I
was walking around Santa Monica yeah no
I didn't particularly enjoy my time
they're happy to be back in the Free
State of Florida but the homeless people
some of them were just yelling at my
fiance and me at the top of their long
speaking all sorts of gibberish I mean
these people are mentally ill okay and
they should not be on the streets so the
point is whether it's homelessness
policy whether it's gun policy you know
this person the shooter whose name I
will not use per my normal custom you
know apparently was seeing a
psychiatrist for some sort of emotional
disorder I actually read that just this
morning and according to both Tennessee
and federal law if I'm not mistaken when
you are in a situation like that you
should not be able to Legal legally
purchase weapons so if the relevant gun
laws were just enforced this never would
have happened in the first place but the
broader points here which I think is the
most important point to make about the
media coverage of this is compare the
media coverage of this to the Buffalo
Supermarket shooting I think was last
April or May where you had an actual
Neo-Nazi white supremacist shoot up a
predominantly black neighborhood if I'm
not mistaken there obviously the media
is all over what is the motive there you
know a hierarchy oppression
intersectionality all this stuff and
here what you have what seems to me to
be a fairly straightforward case of
anti-christian animus obviously the last
thing in the world they want to speak of
is that I think it was Reuters Reuters
had a tweet in the headline earlier this
week where they were like former
Christian School student shoots up
Christian School I mean burying the lead
does not do that Justice no that's
that's beyond burying the lead like that
that we need a new phrase for that when
we saw that one Whoopi also not only did
she say this isn't mental illness she
she said it had nothing to do with the
Trans there like they just the point is
they don't know but because it doesn't
fit the narrative they keep running with
it I want to show you another clip since
we we brought up the gun portion of this
uh this is a CNN reporter at the Capitol
uh in the last couple days in the fall
out of this talking to uh Byron Donald's
from Florida and uh representative Andy
oogles from Tennessee about uh guns so
Second Amendment here in the United
States people are allowed to possess
Firearms need is in the eye of the
beholder
I don't question why you need a blue
suit but you got one and I know we're
talking about something very very
different but the second amendment
allows American citizens to possess
Firearms so why not limit the to the
AR-15s why not why not put a ban on that
if you're going to talk about the AR-15
you're talking politics now let's not
get into politics
all right let's not get into emotion
because emotion feels good but emotion
doesn't solve problems why not ban
AR-15s
why not talk about the real issue facing
this country in regards to the shooting
which would be Mental Health
you know when we talk about these
quote-unquote journalists to me that is
such a perfect example of it because
it's subtle what they do it's not that
he's going out there yelling at the guy
but the way he asked the question so
there's a shooting and immediately the
question should be why don't we do
something against the Second Amendment
so it's it's a trickery in how they're
actually going about the business right
Ashley
yeah that's a classic uh way of what in
in the study of bias is called framing
you frame it right off the bat as as
having to do with guns the questions are
about guns in the answers even in the
negative therefore are about guns so you
just get people saying guns guns guns
guns guns over and over and over and
that also brings in another kind of bias
which is omission bias what is not being
spoken about here and that is a whole
host of other factors and things that
are at play that are all crowded out for
this one three letter word and again uh
let's talk about it sure talk about guns
but you cannot have that conversation at
the exclusion of every single other
factor that might be involved that is
absurd that is exactly what the
gentleman was saying that is politics
that is not journalism
Josh I I don't like playing the games
that the left plays with you know always
blaming a group of people for the
actions of one individual but at what
point if we have an entire mainstream
media that is constantly going after you
know white straight Christians as the
worst people on the planet who have ever
existed
at what point are they somewhat culpable
and I know that is an extremely slippery
slope but but the constant demon is it
there's one group you're allowed to
demonize and that's the group of people
that happen to be killed in this
incident
look from where I'm sitting you know Jew
hatred and anti-christian bigotry are
probably the last two politically
correct forms of bigotry in the United
States today I mean it is not merely not
a problem to criticize Jews and
Christians when they're acting like Jews
and Christians but it is often times it
is praise I mean that will get you
platformed by large swaths of the
liberal media I don't think that's
overstating it and you know I like you I
I tend to try to stick to individual
culpability individuals are responsible
for their actions and all of that there
but the the media as a class has just
such dripping animus and disdain for the
traditional views of religious Jews
religious Christians frankly even just
like you know religious Muslims as well
honestly too and to an extent I think
back to this op-ed that there's only
tangentially related I think back to
this op-ed the New York Times published
a couple weeks ago it was basically
saying that oh the Jews but back at the
time the Torah was given in Sinai oh of
course they supported transgenderism and
like I like are you kidding me I I'm
like what is wrong with you people like
why are you trying to warp what
religious people believe to suit your
very tangential
we're going Israel in a couple weeks I'm
taking my entire team we're gonna do
some shows but are you telling me now I
know that uh you know the that was in
Egypt technically where the Ten
Commandments I've been to the mountain
Mount Sinai but are you telling me that
Moses was not a cross-dresser
I mean Deuteronomy if we want to go
there Deuteronomy literally says that
you shall not wear the opposite sex is
clothing it's like a direct passage
actually but crazy stuff crazy stuff
well I'll get i'll get on I don't know
that we're going to Egypt maybe I can
take a quick bus trip to Sinai I did it
once I don't know how many times I can
do that uh let's move on to uh the other
big thing of the week because Congress
is in session and there are things
happening and we were in DC earlier the
week there really was a certain energy
in DC that was nice to see and I sense
the Republicans are kind of coming
around a little bit on some important
issues but there's still always some
weird language in bills that sound right
that end up kind of being evil uh this
Tick Tock band this potential Tick Tock
band as part of the restrict Act is now
sounding somewhat crazy I want to read a
tweet by Greg price who actually is a a
journalist he uh took a screenshot from
the the bill itself and he wrote this
the build to ban Tick Tock is absolutely
terrifying it gives the government the
ability to go after anyone they deem as
a national security risk at which point
they can access everything from their
computer to video games to their ring
light this is a patriot act for the
internet and then he took a screenshot
of a portion of it I want to read you uh
just the second half all right you know
what I'll do the entire portion a in
general the secretary in consultation
with the relevant executive department
and energy heads is authorized to and
shall take to shall take action to
identify Deets disrupt prevent prohibit
investigate or otherwise mitigate
including by negotiating entering into
or or imposing here we go and enforcing
any mitigation measure to address any
risk arising from any covered
transaction by any person with respect
to any property subject to the
jurisdiction of the United States that
the secretary determines in essence guys
this bill to ban Tick Tock which we can
talk about Chinese spyware on everyone's
phones and what do you do about that
surprise surprise deep within that bill
they will have access to every freaking
thing you have ever done on this device
basically in perpetuity and they said
any about 10 times
uh the kids say problematic I think
Ashley is this a problem
I mean you know the the one thing that's
really the Patriot Act obviously comes
to mind but even more so what comes to
mind is the the CCP the Chinese
government's 2017 National Intelligence
act which gives very similar powers to
the to the Chinese Communist party and
it uses that word any it's really not
about anyone having to meet a legal
threshold it's whatever the person in
charge determines to be relevant in the
case of the of China and the Chinese law
you have to turn over anything that
might be considered actionable or useful
intelligence to the state whether you're
a business or a private private citizen
or or a NGO it doesn't matter and in
this case we're seeing the exact same
kind of language whatever it is it is
covered by the law and this is something
that we need to put the brakes on today
this cannot go any farther my my fear
though is that it will go farther that
it will creep further into it and part
of that is because we don't have a media
that is willing anymore to stand up to
the to the National Security State quite
the opposite we've got a media that is
now working in lockstep with the
National Security State and with the
intelligence community and with law
enforcement the three groups that they
were used to opposing vociferously is
now their their their closest bedfellow
which is crazy and worrying and
disturbing in ways that's really hard to
express yeah they're basically acting as
their PR PR arm at this point uh as of
us doing this right now last I had heard
on this uh Rand Paul who obviously is
the most Libertarian Senator we have he
was bringing this to Josh Hawley Holly
sounds like he's for this at the moment
now Holly wrote a whole book on big Tech
censorship and a bunch more I happen to
like him and I hope he does come around
on this he's really the most populist
Senator there is this strikes me as a
populist issue uh Josh what do you what
do you think is going to happen here
so I could be wrong about this but I I
think Josh Hawley has also proposed
alternative legislation and so it's not
the restrict act okay good so some of
this is happening right now yeah exactly
yeah it's kind of it's kind of actually
unfolding in real time at least the last
I saw this morning so I I think that
Josh Hawley is solid on this the if I
understand correctly the alternative
bill that he has proposed does not
incorporate that very harrowing and
dystopian frankly just orwillian
paragraph that we just heard from you
red on air but what you're really seeing
here and this is just such classic
Congress I mean what they are doing
there with all these ne's that you
emphasize there they are slipping in an
enormous power grab and they are trying
to do so under the uh you know under the
the confines under kind of the ruse of
trying to solve an actual problem and
Tick Tock is an actual problem I mean
you know we should not pretend like it's
not I happen to think that Tick Tock
really should ideally be banned but the
problem is that Congress could do this
in literally a one paragraph maybe like
a one or two sentence Bill if they
wanted to the fact that they felt the
need to kind of emphasize this to this
sent there is just a pure power grab and
frankly honestly it's also a galling
Fourth Amendment violation I mean as a
lawyer by background that's the very
first thing I thought of when I heard
that paragraph there so if this bill
were to somehow pass in that form which
I don't think it will I would expect
some Fourth Amendment lawsuits to stop
it right out of the gate to be honest is
the bigger issue that even by addressing
this let's say the language does get
changed and Holly comes around and okay
we're all feeling somewhat better that
we're sort of just rearranging chairs on
the Titanic as it sinks because so much
of this is is so long gone at this point
we have no idea what the security state
is doing and they s and nobody ever gets
fired nobody gets arrested nobody gets
publicly shamed they lie in front of
Congress that it just won't even matter
whether they remove the specific
language or not Ashley
I think it's
um I think there is a creep there is
definitely a creep into our all of our
Lives privacy is sort of an outdated
outmoded notion at this point though I
think this as Josh was just pointing out
this particular
um section of that bill is so sweeping
and so ambiguous and so expansive that
it feels like that would actually be at
least a catalyst to something very
different we may get there eventually we
probably will at the rate we're going
especially with the introduction of
Central Bank digital currency that gives
government real just you know complete
control complete insight into your
finances your property uh we're we're
heading in that direction there's not
much that's slowing the train down but I
think this kind of language would just
speed it up and put it on steroids and
that's why it's such a concern to me
I got one more clip before we wrap up
today uh Donald Trump was being
interviewed by Sean Hannity and he was
giving credit to Elon Musk for what he's
done with Twitter and you guys know I
I've been to Twitter Elon seems like
he's doing the best he can I still have
a ton of frustrations with Twitter the
numbers still seem completely out of
whack the engagement still seems really
bizarre he called it a fractal Rube
Goldberg machine to me so it's not an
easy thing to clean up but Trump talked
about at least the fact that Elon got in
the fight and whether he's going to get
back on Twitter
by the way Elon Musk revalued Twitter at
only 20 million well it was not uh 20
billion I'm sorry but he did a big favor
by letting people know how corrupt our
government is you know I hear that they
spied in my campaign and at that time
because truth is incredible but at that
time I was using Twitter now I use truth
although I have they want me back on
Twitter desperately are you going to go
back uh well we'll talk about that at
some point but I love truth I think
truth is incredible it's it's up I think
389 percent it's the hottest thing there
is
okay uh Josh
ah just talk what do you got
um so look I mean let's not forget the
Twitter files I mean I share a lot of
the same frustrations that you probably
have Dave with the low engagement
numbers the fact that there's this weird
for you for you column on my iPhone app
for Twitter now
um engagement is just really I I feel
like I'm Shadow banned frankly worse
than ever but let's not forget about the
Twitter files I mean honestly the
Twitter files really kind of I think
makes Elon Musk doing this worth it unto
itself the revelations in there were
absolutely positively striking and they
really just confirmed so much of what
those of us have been saying or
suspecting for years now about this just
naked open collusion between the
National Security State the intelligence
community and Silicon Valley so that in
and of itself I think really did justify
and make this whole experiment that Elon
Musk is doing worth it but really just
more symbolically the fact that someone
could come in there and obviously you
know very few people have you on must
net worth but the the mere example that
someone could kind of come in there like
a white knight and try to pry away a
very prominent and important social
media media platform away from kind of
the Jack Dorsey clown Brigade despite
its CR my current frustrations with
what's happening there and the fact that
we're very far from Perfection there is
some in you know some inherent value in
Merit in that act yeah and by the way as
of March 31st which is today uh Elon
supposedly is open sourcing this thing
that's what he had said in a tweet a
couple weeks ago we'll see if it
actually open sources today and then at
least if it was truly open source you'd
be able to see how your account was
being affected perhaps by the language
you use or inserting a link or saying
something about someone's gender Etc
actually I'll give you the final word
yeah I think on Twitter musk is pretty
clued into where the the tech is going
and the tech is going towards
decentralization it's going towards
um platforms that are open that are
protocol based which means that nobody
owns it it's just like email like no one
owns email you you can use it as you
wish and we're seeing the emergency of
these kinds of platforms or at least
these Technologies like noster's one of
them and farcaster minds.com and it it
what it means is that you can just talk
freely you don't have to ask permission
you have to raise your hand to ask
teacher if you can say this or that and
it also means that when someone says
something hateful or when they express
something that is violent you don't just
kick them off into an even darker corner
of the internet but you're able to
intervene and to help them and not just
banish them into some place that they're
going to make it an even bigger mess so
musk you know if anyone is going to
solve this problem the Twitter problem
or maybe it's even broader than that
social media problem I think it is Elon
Musk I think we think of him as a sort
of engineering guy he's much more than
that he he as as you probably know Dave
better than most people he is an
entrepreneur on a level that is just you
know one of a kind he's he's his own
category so if anyone can fix it it's
musk but he still may not be able to fix
this one right you know as people have
heard me tell the story but you know
when I was there on on day two I mean we
were literally our meeting started at
about midnight and it was 2 A.M and he
he still was like guys I'm really tired
I have he was going to DC the next day
to meet with McCarthy and all these
people and he's like I'm really tired do
you need me to continue here and
everyone was like all right you can go
but the fact that he's there at 2 A.M to
be like Dave were you Shadow band it's
like the guy could be he could buy Bora
Bora
Ashley I can confirm that you have
passed the Reuben report rookie test and
we will have you back thank you Josh are
we gonna let Josh back all right Josh
they said you can come back one more
time uh have a great weekend guys
there's no post game show today because
I got to take care of something but have
a great weekend everyone and we'll see
you on Monday
foreign